nous sommes confronté à une crise à
l'intérieur des communes aujourd'hui les
MRES se désespèrent d'avoir dans leurs
communes des familles qui arrivent qui
ne sont pas du tout intégrés
difficilement parfois intégrables parce
qu'on les met pas au bon endroit vous
savez les maères ils connaissent très
bien leur parc social ils savent qu'il y
a des difficultés dans certaines cages
d'escalier qu'il y a des difficultés
dans certains immeubles en entier et il
faut pas rajouter des difficultés au
difficultés il faut pas rajouter par
exemple de turbulent au turbulent c'est
c'est quelque chose d' extrêmement
important dans l'équilibre territorial
et l'équilibre de population d'une
commune or les maires n'ont plus leur
mots à dire dans l'attribution des
logements les les les artifices
administratifs qu'on a créé font que les
maères n'ont plus de mot à dire ils
n'ont plus leur mot à dire dans le
peuplement de leur commune et ça ça pose
vraiment des problèmes d'équilibre bien
sûr les maires sont en capacité de de
prendre des cas difficiles les maires
son en capacité de prendre des gens plus
modestes c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est de savoir où on les met dans la
ville pour ne pas créer de trouble et
pour leur permettre une bonne
intégration en réalité aujourd'hui le
maire est un des acteurs de la
commission d'attribution mais il n'a pas
la majorité des voix et sa son avis
compte assez peu par rapport aux choix
qui sont faits par les bailleurs et par
la préfecture et donc même s'il donne
son avis même s'il propose des dossiers
ça n'est pas toujours ce ne sont pas
toujours ces dossiers qui sont qui sont
pris et qui sont attribués euh demain ce
que l'on veut et ce que l'on a voté en
fait ici au Sénat c'est que le maire
puisse avoir la majorité au sein de
cette commission d'attribution des
logements qu'il soit le président de la
commission d'attribution des logement et
qu'il ait une voix prépondérante
c'est-à-dire que s'il refuse un dossier
qu'il en ait la capacité